while it won't make you into Ironman
this exosuit can help you walk like one
researchers at the visa Institute in
Massachusetts have constructed a robotic
exoskeleton help stroke victims regain
use of their legs after a stroke nine
out of ten patients are partially
paralyzed and left with an abnormal gait
the soft robotics device provides
assistance to the joints in the lower
leg the results were immediately visible
with its mechanical help the stroke
victims were able to maintain their
balance and walk similar to the way they
had prior to their paralysis the
patients could walk straight for several
minutes on a treadmill some without the
aid of a handrail
while previous assistive devices have
been made these were bulky and had to be
tethered to a power source this new
exosuit is light enough that could be
used to help an overground therapy as
well not just on a treadmill the
researchers say that while it still
needs long-term testing the assistive
device could bring down the time needed
for rehabilitation after strokes
[Music]